okay so let me ask you a question so
obviously back then for Survivor women
needed a man advice when they were
pregnant could die and all of these
things they would perish in today's
society given Evolution given the fact
that as women we can go together yeah
but I'm not saying that isn't there a
glitch between what is actually
happening and the nature of what we have
in our bodies I think that's probably
the conflict that we're having right now
glitching what way in the sense that
women don't feel like they need men in
the most physical sense perhaps like
naturally it's very interesting women
don't feel like they need men in a
physical sense because life is soft but
it's but it's [__] and it's [__]
because you still need Men by proxy one
and two the second life gets difficult
you very quickly you very quickly learn
how much you need men but women don't go
I'm independent I don't need no man
because I haven't only fans and men
being my only fans and if anyone comes
up to me I'll call a male police officer
I don't need men shut up [__] idiot
of course you do you just name your
whole life is based on [__] men the
roads are driving along was paved by a
man the house you're living in was built
by a man the car you're driving who was
designed by a man your whole life
depends on men